okay this is gonna be tight
comedian and actor Joel McHale and I
trying to navigate a deep slot canyon in
the Arizona desert oh my god but it just
became dangerously narrow I'm stuck
going Riggle keep wriggling
[Music]
I'm fine bear you go ahead I'm uh you
know a larger man and there's a lot of
tight crevices this is not a hike for
those that enjoy pizza all the time so
this is this is all from flash-flood
here like barbed wire and everything
yeah it's gonna get very tight yeah you
think it's been getting progressively
narrower you know which kind of gives
you that little bit of claustrophobic
feeling and this is one of the ones
where you just got to take your time
with because the danger of slot canyons
is you get caught in them you get
committed and then you can't get back
out can I just stay here
sure see you later what it's bear this
is you can't leave me for dead I have a
number stand-up dates it's some pretty
prominent local casinos be kind Joe keep
moving okay I'm coming through I'm all
right
I'm fine okay hey we did it yeah looking
good piece of cake yes piece of cake a
very thinly sliced piece of cake there
he he just runs off and then I have to
catch up with them all the time I guess
that's how it works on this show
[Music]